is there um
you know what's dope about being
independent like i know you're indie
right now oh you get all the money you
get all the money
um but i also it's i mean everyone's got
to be knocking on your door trying to
sign you
oh yeah for sure is a lot of people i
mean they've been doing that when i was
in jail it was like
right so what will it take what's
important to you
to even think about that because i don't
think you need to sign with anybody
i don't i mean i'm the most influential
person to come out of here like
everybody wants to be me i always said
that it'd be rappers that'd be like
i want to sign them i'm too big of a
rapper to be signed to another rapper
like i don't know i get enough money
like
to be like for them to be trimming my
money or giving me front of me some
money and then i gotta pay it back
like how am i gonna pay it back right
now anyway if i sign the deal
how am i going to pay that money back
hey you got the right i can't do no
shows
you got the right thought process hey
come on bro i'm not i'm not [ __ ]
because you know everything
right hey i'm gonna pay back 99 out of
100 people will go to that
upfront bag and worry about the
wrestling it's like all the people that
signed autumn deals now they're dead now
yeah you can't do no shows they didn't
french
furniture all this money and then and
then you ain't making money off your
music because you're
cooped come on so i hope you held on to
that event yeah
and know that they did and they did for
sure did it they did
not is he crazy that [ __ ] is crazy